Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my brand new green lantern hbo
video they just made a bunch of big announcements
we know what's going on with the series we know
how many episodes they're doing and we know which
characters they're doing which versions of green
lantern i will be doing episode videos for when
it premieres so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get everything we'll do a new
amazon giveaway too let me know in the comments
what kind of big crossovers do you want them to do
and which other big characters do you want them to
include because they connected everything during
crisis on infinite earths i'll explain where
the series fits between all the dceu movies the
justice league snyder cut and all the arrowverse
stuff that they're doing so we'll number these as
we go along just to stay organized but starting
with the big stuff first the green lanterns that
they're starting with in season one are sinestro
guy gardner alan scott jessica cruz simon bazz
and kilawog on top of that core starting roster
they're also introducing quote unquote new
mystery lanterns that they haven't already
revealed yet for those of you holding out hope
for diggle green lantern showing up on the series
i'll explain that in a second the biggest thing
that everyone noticed when they announced the
roster of green lanterns last week for season
one is that there's no mention of how jordan
or jon stewart which seems weird that they
would do so many green lanterns in season one
but the most popular two wouldn't be part
of that announcement that doesn't mean that
they won't appear on the show it just means that
they won't be main characters during season one
the main reason for that as you probably guessed
is because of the green lantern core movie that
they're still doing there is a green lantern
movie that they're still developing right now
also number four a lot of people are expecting
to see some big green lantern corps debuts in
the justice league snyder cut zack snyder had big
plans for introducing the new dceu versions of the
green lantern characters in the movies they would
have been a much bigger part of the justice league
sequel movies had they done justice league 2 the
way he had planned right now what's happening with
that is that he's still doing his original green
lantern stuff from the first justice league movie
as part of the snyder cut we'll get to see that
sometime around the spring or summer next year
when they release those episodes on hbo max zack
snyder has been teasing so much new green lantern
stuff going into that movie that the thought is
now because they're spending an extra 70 to 80
million dollars or so to finish the snyder cut and
there's no indication that zack snyder will get to
make his version of justice league 2 that'll try
to incorporate some of that lost potential green
lantern sequel stuff into the snyder cut just in
some way remember the original plans for the green
lantern corps movie that movie was originally
supposed to come out earlier this year in 2020
before they postponed it and made all those behind
the scenes changes with the way they make the
movies originally what would have happened is that
zack snyder would have introduced dceu hal jordan
green lantern the same way he introduced wonder
woman in batman v superman and then she went off
to her own solo movie franchise so during justice
league two hal jordan and the green lanterns would
have gotten a really big moment everyone
gets hyped up for dceu green lantern stuff
then they go off to their new solo movie and
start their own green lantern trilogy leading
up to another big justice league crossover like
sinestro core war blackest night the war of light
anything you could possibly imagine obviously
plans have changed since then so they're not
going to be doing stuff like that anytime soon
it would have just led to more big space-based
crossovers the same way avengers infinity
war and avengers end game became big marvel
crossovers between the earth-based avengers movies
and the space based guardians of the galaxy movies
the newer dc movie actors have been teasing
more future crossovers with the justice league
characters they're still doing a new gods movie
with darkseid and the new gods characters so
there's still a lot of big space based crossover
movies that they can do in the future but a lot
of that just depends on how the movies go the
next couple of years number three they didn't
quite explain how they're going to handle all the
green lantern core timeline because alan scott
as they named there he's going to be a
big part of the series is the golden age
green lantern he's way older than the newest
green lanterns like simon baz and jessica cruz
it's a little more believable that people like
guy gardner sinestro kilowog would be mentors to
simon bass and jessica cruz early on alan scott
does appear in some crossover events with modern
justice league and green lantern heroes during
justice society crossovers but the way warner
brothers in dc talked about the series last year
they made it sound like they're actually going
to be jumping around in the timeline so a lot of
the allen scott green lantern stuff in the series
might wind up being a combination of old man alan
scott and then flashbacks to when he was a young
brand new green lantern like showing him creating
his special lantern battery from the star heart
for those of you that actually keep up with a lot
of the tv series you'll remember that they also
just introduced his green lantern battery on the
star girl tv series but it's cracked he's either
missing or dead we don't know where he is in the
context of that series and the justice society
characters the lantern just started glowing
again meaning it's getting ready to select
a new wielder of alan scott's green lantern
ring but we don't know who that is yet
his lantern ring is a little bit different from
how jordan's and the other modern green lanterns
he forged it himself with instructions given to
him by the star heart the other green lanterns are
gifted their rings at the behest of the owens in
the great lantern battery number two as you would
all probably expect sinestro will eventually be
the main villain but because they're telling the
story of the saga of the entire green lantern
corps history he probably won't start out being
the main villain maybe over the course of season
one or future seasons we'll see his slow descent
becoming more and more hardcore until he takes the
yellow lantern ring and forms the sinestro core
if you've been keeping up with the boys on amazon
it parodies a lot of dc and marvel comics like the
justice league and avengers characters we're
seeing the slow descent of the main character
homelander who's sort of an analog for superman
like an evil version of superman becoming more
and more hardcore we could see a version of that
for sinestro on the series i know there's a lot
of ryan reynolds questions too in terms of
ryan reynolds green lantern references crisis
on infinite earths the multiverse connecting all
the movies and tv shows is pretty clear from the
flash crossover scene with ezra miller and grant
gustin that they want to say that yes everything
is connected to the multiverse but that doesn't
mean that you'll see all the characters crossing
over all the time it's just them saying yes all
these other versions are still valid all these
movies and tv shows even though all the brand new
movies will kind of be doing their own things with
the characters so when it comes to referencing the
ryan reynolds green lantern movie some of the same
people that worked on that movie are working on
the green lantern hbo series so ryan reynolds
himself probably will not cameo just because
the uber deadpool marvel cinematic universe
contract he's in the process of signing marvel's
locking him down hardcore for a long time but they
probably will make a lot of references and jokes
about that old green lantern movie this is one of
their opportunities with this new hbo series to
fix a lot of the issues that everyone had with
that even just a little while ago ryan reynolds
was posting more funny green lantern videos
he was promoting his new movie free guy with taika
wattidi which is coming up next year but i think
a lot of people have forgotten that taekoobatiti
also appeared in the original green lantern movie
because he is an actor and a director this is both
of them making fun of that green lantern movie
didn't you guys do a movie together yeah
i think who did you guys talking about
i don't think so not from mummy brother this
is the first time we've met green lantern yeah
that was yeah green lantern using them you
understand what we can learn from can't stay
here what gotta go what pilot he wore a uniform
i think he was a soldier give me this proposed
i don't think so that maybe you're thinking of
um jessica tandy seth rogen green hornet that's
it yeah that's where you're getting confused
you're amazing in that but neither of us are cf
i did no you did green lantern it was definitely
green line right he was also posting justice
league snyder cup memes a while ago editing
himself into the ending of the original
theatrical cut of justice league so regardless
of what they do with the new series or the new
green lantern movies just expect ryan reynolds to
continue making fun of himself but in terms of the
newer stuff the hbo max show will be connected
to the new green lantern core movie in some way
that also kind of explains what's going on with
hal jordan and jon stewart and why they weren't
named as part of that big announcement they'll
probably debut in the brand new movie first before
we see them on the tv show so they'll wait to
cast them until they get ready to make the movie
in a course number one everybody's wondering
as for diggle green lantern during that arrow
series finale he got his green lantern ring and
said he was moving with his family to metropolis
metropolis is near smallville where the upcoming
superman tv show is going to take place next year
so it doesn't take a genius to guess that they'll
eventually follow up with diggle on the superman
show and some crossover cameos but because they're
doing all the newer more obscure green lanterns on
the hbo series and introducing quote-unquote
new mystery green lanterns also on the show
the chances that diggle shows up on that just
shot up a thousand percent but that's something
that they would probably keep pretty secret the
aerovoice shows are only kind of connected to
the hbo max series that they're developing right
now like they have a justice league dark series
that they're working on that's probably going
to feature a new version of constantine there's
also a separate version of a new constantine show
that they're developing for hbo max 2 that might
wind up being a different actor from matt ryan
they haven't confirmed who they're going to cast
as the new version of constantine but in terms
of brand new green lantern movie stuff i would
love as you would probably guess for john david
washington to be the new jon stewart i feel like
that would actually be a really big slam dunk but
he himself actually did say that if he was going to
go for a comic book movie he was talking more
about being the new mr fantastic inside the marvel
cinematic universe in whatever their new fantastic
four movie winds up being so if you have any big
questions or any big requests about what's going
on with the new hbo max dc series just let me know
in the comments below and i'll just keep doing
videos as we find out new information everyone
click here for the boys season 3 teaser trailer
and click here for that superman trailer for
the new tv series thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!